[Music]
hey guys how are you today hola mi gente
i almost forgot i like saying it i don't
know it's like a tiny little piece of my
culture that i get to bring onto these
vlogs for you guys
um that's the reason why i always make
it a point to be like oh yeah i forgot
to say hola migente which means hello my
people
for those of you that don't know anyway
how are you guys today is another
beautiful day
i decided i wanted to make a video all
about
how i feel about my tesla my car so if
you guys don't know i have
a tesla model three and i bought it
december
2018. we're coming up on the two-year
anniversary of this car
but before i go into talking about the
tesla and stuff i did want to
go give it a nice little car wash a nice
little tlc
you know so that's my plan is to go get
a car wash
but before that though i did want to
just
connect with you guys and just be like
hey have you guys been because i've been
pretty good and also i did want to show
you guys something new about me
i don't know if you guys already noticed
but ta-da i am no longer blue haired tip
so my girl lindsay who always does my
hair
she did a house call and it was crazy
because it was the day before lockdown
so
here in california there we have a new
lockdown now
and it's like i think i guess like a
three-week lockdown or something so
apparently this is like way crazier than
the first lockdown
they're trying to be a lot more strict
and so
leading up to that lockdown i was like
oh my gosh lindsay is there any way
you could just squeeze me in somewhere
in your schedule please like
even a house call because the salon was
booked during that time so she was like
yeah girlfriend don't even trip i got
you so
she came over and luckily she was able
to just do a quick
i think she calls it like a toner or i
don't even know the
hair style terms but the point is she
was able to get the blue out
and now i'm fully brown all natural
like i got over being blue hair tip i
don't know i just i got that out of my
system now because the first time i dyed
my hair
it was very short-lived like the very
first time i got blue hair it was very
short-lived because
shortly after that i went brown for the
wedding and then
after the wedding was done i was like oh
man i didn't really get to scratch that
itch
of having blue hair and now it's been
like three years i think
and now i'm like okay i'm good like i'm
pretty good
yeah we can just go back to being
natural i don't know if i'm gonna be
doing any more crazy colors
but who knows because i was in between
getting pink hair or going natural
because i did have like that the the
hair primed and prepped for
another color because it was already
bleached and that is like a whole
process there so i was just really
considering it i'm like well
if i still want another color would it
be pink and
would i be happy with that and i
ultimately decided like you know what i
think i'm over it i'm over the colors
so here we go this is what i got now i
am considering
maybe chopping it off again because i
really did like having a bob
but i don't know it's kind of a lot of
work so i'm sitting here looking at my
desk and
look at what is so freaking cute as you
guys know we're investors with june b
for example the matcha that we always
talk about and delicious like ceremonial
grade matcha that is sourced from japan
is just amazing and we have
like winged chicks shrimp daddy and
chichidongo as well but anyway the group
that we're with
they gave us a holiday present and look
they made these cookies that says
happy holidays tan clan how freaking
cute is that
that's so adorable and they also gave us
like this holiday card
they're like oh happy holidays and all
that stuff
it was really sweet we recently opened
it because they gave us the gift
and we went to one of the founders their
baby shower and we did like a drive-by
baby shower so it was pretty cute
and at that baby shower they gave us
this gift and they're like don't open it
until we have our meeting and so we're
like okay okay so we held on to it for
like a few days
and that was part of the gift and then
they also gave us these like really cool
cups that enhance flavor and whatever
you put in it so that was pretty cute
and i'm just sitting here like staring
at this and i'm like oh and seeing this
honestly just it reminds me of our trip
to japan because last year
we we all went to japan as a group so it
just makes me think of japan and how
beautiful that country is
and luckily we actually have a new
sponsor for this video that is tied to
japan so thank you to baksu for
sponsoring this video so if you don't
know anything about baksu it's this
amazing
monthly snack box subscription that
brings you
premium japanese snacks straight to your
door and it's crazy because they partner
with
family snack makers that have been in
business for like over a hundred years
they partner with them in order to bring
you these
amazing delicious japanese snacks
personally i've been such a fan of
japanese snacks because they just have
like the perfect texture and the flavors
like they nailed the flavors
so well and so once boku hit us up and
they were like oh you guys want a
partner i'm like
yes i've been missing japan and to
like you know during this pandemic like
at least to get a tiny slice
of japan at my door through snacks is
like
heaven right now because it really i
really genuinely have been missing that
country so i have
my own boxu right here i'm going to be
opening it with you guys and it's so
cool because with each box you receive
they have a new theme which means the
snacks are always different
and they'll be taking you through a
gourmet journey throughout japan in
every single box so are you ready to
open it because i am i'm so excited i've
been saving
these snacks for this unboxing because
i'm like oh my gosh i want you guys to
see too premium japanese snacks by baksu
this month is seasons of japan
and they also give you this cultural
guide so you get to see
what is inside your box and they
just guide you through every single
snack and the theme so they even tell
you if there's like allergies or what
else it contains like
for example like milk and eggs and they
explain
every single snack that's in this box so
you get to learn each snack and what it
contains and
also they just show you where each snack
is from
throughout the entire country of japan
so oh my gosh this is so cool
so here we have some yummies they even
give you some tea
oh my goodness which one should i try
oh cute suck it candy
it's strawberry so it's like chocolate
strawberry all right so i'm gonna try
the white strawberry
and it says here that this is the
world's first chocolate
juice strawberry oh chocolate infused
strawberry
oh my god it smells amazing look it's an
actual strawberry look at that
[Applause]
cool see japan never fills with their
snacks ma'am
it's always so delicious i can't wait to
go through that entire box i'll be
sharing with casey and
isaac and you know what with the
holidays coming up
why not treat yourself and get yourself
a baku some
japan snack and also you can share this
with your loved ones because for example
we wanted to show appreciation to our
video editor
antoine shout out to you and we sent him
a box a box food box for himself to
enjoy oh my god they have donuts
they have donuts i am a happy editor
pc was like you know what editing is too
crazy and so luckily antoine came
and saved the day and so we wanted to
show him appreciation with
one of these baksu boxes so join us and
thousands of others and experiencing
authentic
japanese flavors get yourself a
subscription
use our code tiffcase10 for 10 off we'll
have a link in the description as well
and let me know how you enjoy these
amazing japanese snacks so
anyway let's go off and wash my car
and i'll tell you all about my tesla
[Applause]
[Music]
baby
all right so my car is now nice and
clean
i was unable to film any part of the car
wash for you guys because
this new car wash that i went to they
required me to get
a hand wash for the because of the fact
that it's a tesla which i have never
encountered in
previous car washes so i thought that
was kind of weird but for that reason i
didn't want to film
the guy cleaning my car because i don't
know the guy so i just felt weird
filming him so
anyway the car is clean now i decided to
park in front of the garage so you guys
can have more lights because now that
it's winter time
fall time whatever the sun sets a lot
earlier
so i'm like trying to squeeze this video
in right before sunset now the car is
clean i can talk about it like i said
earlier i'm coming up on two years with
this car
i know a lot of you guys have been
curious to know what my opinions are on
my car
and to tell you the truth like just flat
out i
am completely 100 okay not 100 but like
99.9
in love and obsessed with my car i've
absolutely loved it the moment i got it
it's just felt like
riding like driving a spaceship
completely different experience
having this car then the obviously than
the previous car i had because i had
a 2010 honda civic but not just that but
like the fact that this car has like
this gigantic screen and it just feels
like i am driving like a i'm driving the
car version
of an iphone it's what i feel like my
favorite thing about the car
is that there's always updates happening
like randomly there'll be a new update
and all of a sudden i have a whole bunch
of new features that my car didn't have
before
what other car can do that like i don't
know there is that 0.1
that does irritate me like there are a
few things about this car that i'm gonna
be completely honest with you about i do
have the autopilot on my car initially
when i first got it
it was only able to be enacted when
i'm on the freeway like i can only
activate it when i'm on the freeway but
now i can actually have
autopilot on with the streets regularly
but obviously it doesn't respond to
red lights or stop signs personally i
don't like using autopilot on the street
so i will just only use it on the
freeway but the annoying part about it
is that sometimes depending on like the
lighting like the visibility
sometimes like when i drive under a
bridge
and there's like in the daytime and
there's like a huge shadow
because of the fact that i go into the
bridge sometimes like the autopilot will
be like
like glitching a little bit like whoa
like what just happened what happened to
the light
and it will kind of get a little too
close to cars and so
when i'm on autopilot i never 100 trust
the car
i'm constantly having my hands on the
wheel i have my
my foot hovering over the pedals for
whatever can happen because i already
know that this car
is not 100 foolproof like it it will get
glitchy like that sometimes another
thing that i noticed with autopilot
on the freeway is that if i'm on the far
right lane and
there's another car like merging into
the freeway sometimes the car won't
respond to that
and it'll just keep going and then like
the other car is like hey man i can't
get in so then i have to press the brake
to
get off of autopilot and let that car in
because i do notice that has happened
but like i said the car is constantly
updating and these
issues with autopilot it was early on
when i had the car now that i've had it
for
two years now and because of the updates
it does seem
as though it they have improved a lot of
these tiny little bugs another thing
that was
really really like annoying about this
car is
only with like a few months of me having
this car all of a sudden the
the air in the ac started smelling like
mold it was disgusting and i was just
like what the heck this is like a brand
new car like why am i having these
issues with the air vent and so i took
it in
because at the same time i was having
some sort of like computer glitch too
where the car was reading that one of my
tire pressures was
low but it wasn't and so anyway i took
the car in to check that out they ended
up saying that there wasn't
a computer issue and for me to just put
air in my tire and i did
and it did seem to go away so i guess i
i was
like not attentive of my air tires i
don't know that whole air tire thing was
weird because i'm like listen it's
it was fine the pressure was fine but
the car wasn't reading it
so that's what i mean by little glitches
like that computer glitches is annoying
but anyway the air vent stuff the guy
was saying that it was a common thing
with these model three cars
that as soon as like people get it the
what is it called the air filter
would just get really moldy and musty
and gross and you have to
change it right away so i'm like that
sucks like this is a brand new car like
why why is the filter not gonna last
like i said i've had this air filter
issue
for a long time and just recently i
purchased the new air filters because
the guy even told me he was like don't
come back here and get it done because
they're gonna charge you way too much
it's super easy just look online
you should just do it yourself so i'm
like okay cool and that was like a long
time ago
and just now i i finally bought the air
filter so i need to do that because
still
every single time i get into my car it
does smell
and it smells really bad and it's just
something that i've been meaning to do
but
i was actually planning on doing it for
this video like showing you guys how i'm
gonna change my air filters but because
of the fact that i'm running out of
light i'm just gonna do it on my own but
that's the reason why i haven't done it
yet because i've been saving it for this
video but anyway moving on so
that yeah the air vent thing was a huge
huge like what the heck
you know for this car another downfall
that i can tell you about this car
is up here there is just this glass
right
and i purchased this shade or this glass
because during the summer time and
whenever it's like really hot and the
sun is like
beaming down on my head it felt
hot like it actually was bothersome to
the point where i needed to purchase
this shade like this window shade here
and ever since i got this
it's been a lot more pleasant to drive
this car
because like i said during those hot
months like i really felt my hot my head
get hot even though like
like tesla already they already have
their glass
um like specially tempered or whatever
the terminology is
where it does shield you from the uv
rays
to a certain extent and i did get my car
tinted and i did get this
this glass tinted as well i think i
don't remember now but it's still it was
too hot so i still got
this thing and it has been very helpful
so if you're having the same problem i
recommend you get this
shade thingy i got it on amazon so you
can just google or
amazon it and then it'll be there but
let's go back to the stuff that i love
about this car
i did get the white seats which i've
talked about in the past and it's just
i absolutely love it and i know a lot of
people are like oh my gosh why would you
get white seats like they're gonna get
so dirty it's so crazy blah blah blah
but
tesla i don't know if other car makers
have this exact material too available
for their cars but tesla like they have
this vegan leather
that is super easy to clean and like i
always wear
jeans when i when i am driving my car
and so eventually
on the car seat it'll start having like
some jean
like bluish jeans stuff happen to the
the seat
but as soon as i get a rag like a
microfiber towel
and just wet it a little bit with just
water it immediately comes off
so this material is freaking amazing so
i am
totally not even worried about spills or
anything like that because
this material is really good for getting
it clean the thing that i i
really was kind of concerned about was
the actual
floor so i purchased this kit for like
all weather mats
and so now i really don't have any
concerns because i even bought a mat
from my trunk
i bought a mat from my frunk and for
like all four of these seats
so whenever we go we would go to the
beach we would take this car still
because
it really holds up really well because
even on the side like the door panels
and stuff like
with the scuff mark from the shoes i can
just easily wipe it and it's no big deal
like this car actually holds up pretty
dang well but another thing that i
actually
kind of like that like i said i don't
know all cars i don't know what other
features
other cars have but this car has this
really cool feature that it's like it
you can hold the car so when i hard
press the brake
it will actually like if i'm on the road
and like there's
there's a red light and i i need to stop
for a long time i'll hard press the
brake
and it'll just hold my car so i don't
have to put it in park i can just let go
of the brake and it's completely
fine and as soon as i press the gas
pedal or i tap the brake again it'll
release the hold and keep going so i
have a feeling other cars have that
feature but
i don't like i said i don't know but i
really love that about my car i've
gotten so spoiled that whenever
i'm in the drive-through lane or
whatever like i just i don't ever
hold my break for too long i just hold
it like i tap it and hold it and then
let go and i'm like chilling so i really
like that about my car
i feel really spoiled to have that
little feature oh and then it was really
cool too because
my car got this update a few months ago
where i'm now i'm able to see the
cameras from both sides of my car so now
i can see
from the back and on both sides so it
looks like this is what it looks like
now
so i can see on my left side on my right
side and behind because in the past when
i first got my car it was only the rear
rear view mirror but i love how they
updated it and then now i can see
both sides so that was really cool other
features that they've added to this car
that
like since i've had the car is they've
added netflix hulu
youtube twitch and all these things like
they they have it under like the theater
option just super cool they didn't have
that when i first got this car
and i felt really lucky because for
years tesla owners have been
like begging for for this feature it's
like for you to
be able to watch anything when you're in
park like whenever you're supercharging
your car whatever it takes like about 45
minutes so
it'd be super awesome if you could
actually use this screen to watch
something like for entertainment and so
finally i think uh i think maybe like
less than six months after i got the car
they updated it and i was so thrilled
because i'm like oh my gosh i feel so
spoiled i didn't have to wait years and
years like other other
tesla guys but um yeah so i really love
that feature
and there's also an arcade and they have
fallout this stardew valley
so i guess like kind of like farming
backgammon cuphead
which isaac was absolutely thrilled with
because he's a big cuphead fan
and so he plays this one everywhere in
my car and then there's beach buggy
where you actually use the steering
wheel or your car
and you can actually race and there's
also
if you go to i think it's toy box here
my car can fart so i'm sure you guys
know this already it's like some old
tesla stuff but
yeah so the car totally boards
that's so stupid it's so immature and so
dumb but it's really funny
like what other car is gonna do that
and then also i can fart on turn signal
so
if i turn ah
it just starts working yeah that's like
the dumbest feature ever but it's
really fun like it actually brings me
joy so i i appreciate it but i i don't
even turn it on the only time i ever get
to play with this feature is whenever
i'm showing someone else
that's it the other cool thing is you
can make beats so on this like tracks
thing
i can just make my own beats or whatever
isaac's played with it there's also a
romance
feature where once i turn this on the
whole screen turns into this like
fireplace
the actual vent will start heating up so
like it will give you like warm air
and then it also has like this romance
playlist so play like
some saudi and stuff and then there's
like the sketch pad you can just draw
things
and there's like a mars mode where the
whole map turns into mars and then your
car
is like this little lunar rover kind of
thing and
appropriate for the holidays there's a
santa mode
you can jingle all the way
all right so i don't even know if that
music made the edit because of content
id
but it does have some christmas music
and then the last thing here is
rainbow road so when i'm on autopilot i
can activate this
and it'll turn the whole road into a
rainbow that's pretty cool
yeah there's just a ton of features on
this car
it's super fun to play with obviously
when you're parked there's just so many
fun things about this car that i can
honestly say
that i would highly recommend anyone to
get this car it's just so freaking fun
also i just love the way it drives too
because it's so smooth comparing it to
my honda
like i would be flooring it on the gas
like trying to get into
the the freeway and it just would be
like
struggling to gain any type of
acceleration
obviously it's a honda civic but still i
got just
comparing that to what the tesla does
now like i'll tap it a little bit and go
like
so it's just it's really it drives
really well and it's also
super safe too so it has this one
feature where it will like start
alarming
like if i'm driving and i'm not slowing
down fast enough and there's like a car
in front of me it'll start beeping at me
like hey [ __ ]
pay attention i'll be like oh snap so
then i'll i'll break
so i feel extra safer in this car too
because of the fact that i just know
that this car
has my back you know for the most part
this car i feel completely safe in
and i've genuinely been very happy with
this car
um i can't even honestly i can't see
myself drive
another car like a different car for my
daily driver because i've just gotten so
used to this car i did have to buy a few
things for this car
just to make my car more comfortable so
like i already mentioned
the weather mats i mentioned this shade
thing
and i know i've already told you guys in
the past but i'll tell you again
i ended up wrapping this entire thing
white
because when i got the car it was this
shiny black material which i wasn't a
big fan of so
i ended up just covering all this and i
bought this vinyl piece on amazon as
well
so i bought a whole bunch of stuff i
also added the red teas which i've told
you guys in the past too i put red teas
all over the car and just to give it a
little personality
flavor that's not really necessary this
i do
find necessary because of the fact that
i got it matte it has
helped my car feel a lot cleaner because
with the
actual shiny black stuff it constantly
was smudgy so i don't know if you guys
can tell but it's like really
plasticky and it just felt cheap because
obviously this is
tesla's more affordable model so they're
not going to be all lavish with the
materials so i personally
wanted to cover this and ever since i
have covered it it has given my car
a better feel another thing i i did was
i bought this wireless charger the
company is called
nomad yeah i bought this wireless
charger because if not for this wireless
charger there were these
plug-ins down here and i would have to
like manually find
the actual charger and it would be like
this like situation where i'm going like
this like trying to like actually plug
it in and then
finally plug it in and there you go so
now i don't have to worry about that
now that i've upgraded to this wireless
charger it's made my life a lot easier
which i appreciate so yeah honestly
getting these upgrades
or not upgrades but like these
aftermarket products i guess i could
call them
they have made my car a lot better in my
opinion it's made my life easier in a
lot of ways
and yeah so i would highly recommend
those aftermarket products as well
oh another thing that i really love
about this car is that you can set
driver profiles and i know you can do
that in other cars but i don't know
how specific you can really make your
car in other cars to each driver so for
example
you're able to set your seat exactly how
you want it which i know it's very
common
but not only that you can actually set
your lumbar support so
down here and this is this is a brand
new discovery by the way
isaac discovered that i have a lumbar
support
on my seats i didn't even know that and
he just told me maybe like two three
weeks ago like this brand new discovery
but in the seat down here there's this
lumbar support so there's like a little
like balloon kind of thing that
inflates and gives you more support for
your lower back or it deflates if you
don't want so much
which i thought was freaking cool
because i
absolutely love lumbar support stuff so
anyway you can do that and when you set
your driver profiles you can
adjust that and you can also adjust your
your seats
seat temperature you can adjust the
mirrors the side mirrors you can also
adjust the type of
driving you want so for example mine's
on comfort mode i think and then casey's
is on sports mode so the car drives
slightly different
and you're able to also adjust the
steering wheel exactly how you want it
so you can make it
be like more out more in more up more
down or whatever you want and it adjusts
per
driver profile so that's freaking cool i
don't know how much detail
other cars can do that but you can do
that for this one and so
i actually set a driver profile called
lace l-a-y
and that's because whenever i'm parked
for an extended amount of time like for
example when i take isaac to his ortho
appointments
these days i can't be in the waiting
room anymore so i'm waiting in my car
and so i'll set it to lay which looks
like this
so i set it all the way down and then i
turn on my netflix or my hulu
and i just start watching something and
it's so freaking comfy
and for that reason for the reason of
this of the lay
situation i have a pillow in my car
at all times and some sort of blanket
so i am just living it up
in this car it's so freaking comfy i
absolutely love it
even when i'm like super charging or
something i just set it to lay and
sometimes i'll take a nap if i have
enough time but
yeah it's super cool my most favorite
favorite thing that i actually
show everyone every time like right when
i first got my car
like this was my most favorite feature
to show everybody so
once you look at the vent stuff you see
how the airflow is going like this
you can actually change the airflow to
be however you want so
it could be hitting me directly it could
go under it could go
up and if i spread my two fingers i
could make it go away from my face
isn't that freaking cool like what other
air vents do that because if you look at
my car
there are no vents that i can actually
touch and
like move myself i can't really i can't
do that
so i need the car to do that so that's
freaking cool like
i am so obsessed with this feature but
also when you look at the seat warmer
feature
look at this every single seat has
a seat warmer that is so
freaking cool i don't know about you but
that blew my mind when i discovered this
so for example if i want to make the
middle seat to be nice and warm i can
heat that
up right from here so it's pretty cool
or you can set it like lower
and also if you go right over here you
can turn on
this event which by the way check this
out two usb
ports so people can charge their phones
back here
it does have that feature so you're able
to move the vent
wherever you want that's freaking
awesome i don't know man that's freaking
amazing oh
also for the glove box i can't open it
any way
shape or form like there's no button for
you to open in this glove box it must
be opened through the screen i mean can
you like ever focus camera once i click
the
glove box then you can open it
see ta-da so it's really cool whenever
i take my car to the valet it has a
valet feature
so once i enable that the valet can't go
past a certain amount of speed i think
it's like past 20 miles an hour or
something like that
and then they're unable to unlock the
front because there's no engine and
they're not able to unlock the glove box
either so it feels really safe like your
valuables will not get messed with
if you set it on ballet mode very safe
and then to take it off valet mode you
have to put in like
a code whatever code you pick and so it
feels really safe to keep my stuff in
there
another thing is that there are cup
holders so
that's pretty nice because sometimes i
run out of cup holders up here
and then if i want to i can actually
open all of this
and it'll give me access to the trunk
also there's this little hook here so
whenever i have things to hang like
things on a hanger
i can just pop this out it's a little
hook thingy those little hooks
it's at least something because another
negative
at least in isaac book is that there are
no
handrail thingies like you can't hang on
up here like other cars so isaac was
pretty bummed about that because he
really liked that um
handle thingy that's on the door so
tesla model 3 does not have that
but it does have this cool thing for the
mirror so when you drop the visor down
you do have a mirror here but the cool
thing about this mirror
is that if you could just open it
halfway if you want
see and then if you open it all the way
the light turns on but then you don't
want this little flat thingy
so then you can put it right up
and there you go so most of the time i
actually have it this way
for myself because sometimes i just need
to peek really quick and be like oh do i
have any moko's no i'm good
nice makos means boogers by the way in
case you didn't know
do i have any right now you guys you
guys let me know right okay anyway and
here
the hand rest thingy this you can lift
up and there's a whole bunch of stuff in
here
and then right here is where you can put
the um
i forgot this thing is called but this
thingy
for your car so you can charge other
stuff so this is what came with the car
these wires that i'm showing you is what
used to be
here this thing used to stick up like
this and i have to like figure out where
to
plug my phone in but not anymore ever
since i got that
another cool thing that i thought was
pretty cool that my car
my previous car didn't have is this rear
view mirror right here
and the side mirrors they have this like
special tint
thing in it that when when i'm driving
at night
and there's someone with like their high
beams on for example
because of whatever tints these mirrors
have it actually doesn't blind me
so it does help me lessen the intensity
of the lights
that are behind me whenever i'm driving
which i really appreciate that feature
because i didn't know how much i needed
that feature
until i had it because i'm like this is
cool another cool thing
and i'm sure like every single clip is
going to start with me saying and
another thing and another
another cool thing i would show you the
map but i don't want you to know where i
live
so i won't show you but i'll just tell
you with the map itself
it's like a google view right like a
satellite view
of where we are so whenever i'm driving
through really rich neighborhoods like
i'll park or something and i'll be a
freaking stalker and like zoom in on the
google satellite in the tesla
screen and then i could see like dang
they have they have three swimming pools
no one needs that many swimming pools
that's amazing like why does someone
even have
need all that or whatever but so i
really like the fact that there's this
gigantic
map on the screen and i get to be
a weird creepy nosy person as i'm
driving by people's property
and then also like whenever it's night
time it automatically
will set it to night mode so the entire
map will just turn like
black black and white or whatever so
it's not super bright
like it is during the daytime i think
that pretty much covers
how i feel about my car the cool
features that i think
are really cool about my car i know it's
like this video is so
overdue because like i said i'm coming
up on two years with this car i could
have always done it last year but
whatever two years with this car
um i would still highly recommend this
car
the tesla model 3. i can't speak for the
other teslas because i don't know them
they are
very different i think from at least for
example like the model x to the model 3
completely different so i can't speak on
those features or any of those cards but
at least for the model 3
i can tell you i absolutely love it um
i see myself driving this car for a very
very very long time
and especially like i said how they're
constantly updating the features i feel
like i'll never get tired
of this car it always feels like it's a
new car freaking love it
um oh i didn't even tell you this other
part another cool
thing you guys know how how cars have
like car keys right
not my car my car has a key
it's a it's a card key it's a key card
it's a i i enter my car with the card
this is freaking cool like i i don't
know any other car that
only has a card for their key this is
pretty sweet i love this
but i almost never use this you know why
because i have the tesla app
and my phone acts like my key so i
almost
never touch keys ever because once i get
home i just
open the garage with the programmed
thing like as soon as i approach the
garage it just
opens it by itself and because of that
reason like i
never have to even touch house keys ever
so i love that about this car
it's my absolute favorite thing about
this car is that i never have to touch
keys or worry about my car keys or
anything like that as long as i have my
phone so that's freaking cool
and then also from the app i can do so
many things so this is the tesla app and
as you can see
we named the car tick for tiffany isaac
and casey it's freaking cute i know
but yeah so from here you can actually
play
media you see that my phone is the key
i can also control the climate from this
app so i can even turn on the seat
warmers and set the temperature
all that cool stuff and i could also set
it on ballet mode here
set it on sentry mode which is actually
whenever people approach my car
it shows like this big red eyeball here
on the screen and it's saying sentry
mode like recording activated or
something so if anyone approaches the
car
and they just so happen to glance inside
the car they'll see
that all the cameras are recording
whatever's happening so i
really feel like my car is really safe
and i could also set the speed limit
or i can vent the windows so for example
so now i just vented the entire car
which is probably a bad idea because i
just got my car wash but it's okay and
then i can close it
i could also lock my car i could honk it
i couldn't
remotely start it i could open the front
the trunk
flash my light i could also summon my
car
what the heck this is some like future
stuff man
i could move my car forward or backwards
or
if i am at this shopping place like for
example one time isaac and i were
grocery shopping
and i parked really close by the door
like the grocery store door but
there were no cars around so i just
really wanted to use this new feature
because at that time it was like a brand
new feature that they
they downloaded onto my car and the
summon feature it's like
i can literally make my car come to me
what
like that is crazy that's some
futuristic stuff like i totally live in
the future it's freaking crazy
and so we tried it and we just saw the
car uh like
get out of the parking spot and then
like turn and then literally like park
right up to where we were i felt like i
owned the batmobile or something it was
freaking crazy
so i don't usually use that feature very
often but sometimes if i'm in a really
tight parking spot for example i'll use
the summon feature and i'll reverse my
car
or move it up or whatever i need it to
do and
it does that without anyone inside the
car and
it seems really scary because you're
like what if it hit something or
something happens but the
the cameras are actually really good
where it's really good about
not getting too close to object um and
so i
i really love that feature it also has
auto park feature which i know is
very common with cars but yeah man this
car is super high tech
like i said highly recommend it let me
know if you guys have any other
questions about my car
that you might be curious about i hope i
answered
anything that you might have been
curious about and i hope you enjoyed
this video
i keep trying to like run in my mind
like is there anything else i want to
share with you guys about my car
another cool thing
[Music]